you guys want to see a phone camera
battle we got one for you right here the
xiaomi 12s Ultra with a one inch sensor
from Leica and xiaomi versus the brand
new iPhone 14 pro Max with a 48
megapixel sensor which one will win win
photos and in video let's find out right
now
we're doing a front-facing camera we're
doing a video test with this right now
actually recording myself here great
dynamic range from the Apple iPhone your
brand new 12 megapixel sensor on this
looking great looking fantastic good
stabilization shooting 4K 24 as you got
to do because Apple can do that and a
lot of uh these Android phones can't but
uh let's now try
show me all right now we are shooting
with the front-facing camera here on the
xiaomi but it only does 1080 at 30. so
the iPhone automatically wins on this
um a lot of I would say the
stabilization on this could be better
than the iPhone this is pretty damn
stable but in terms of the overall look
the colors I got to give it to the
iPhone on this I think apple is raining
Supreme on this they've always had with
the front facing camera they're doing a
good job xiaomi's not quite there yet
but we haven't got to the main one inch
sensor yet we're still playing around
with the smaller cameras thus far okay
so now I'm actually recording max
resolution here on the uh 12s Ultra AK
24p with the 12s Ultra now the iPhone
doesn't do 8K so obviously the xiaomi
will win in terms of resolution or will
it we're gonna find out because I'm
gonna record in 4k 24 we're gonna see
which one is better and we are doing
this in lower light situations so we're
going to be pushing these cameras
tonight so now let's move to the iPhone
now we are testing out the iPhone of 14
pro Max 4K 24p rear camera here I got to
say iPhone's uh color science has always
been really good the videos those
capabilities have always been really
good so I'm guessing this might be the
one to go with cause are you really
going to shoot with AK all the time no
but how does the AK look versus the 4K
it's not always about the numbers anyway
let us know in the comment section below
now let's move on to some photography
so just First Impressions after using
that I got to say the iPhone's much
easier to hold and use and I do like
that you have a two to three times
optical zoom and I'm putting an asteroid
next event because you're actually just
cropping into the sensor versus a true
optical zoom but Apple's calling it that
so we'll call that for this video this
one just has a three times zero and
obviously a wide so you're not going to
have as much flexibility on the xiaomi
12s Ultra versus this but
this one inch sensor doesn't make a
difference
I think it does I really think it does
and I'm going to do some other tests
with it we're going to find out how good
this sensor is and does it match up to
the 40 megapixels here
oh this is going to be a Battle Royal
all right so you know let's shoot some
lights
First Impressions off that the xiaomi is
going to be a slower camera and lower
light situation but you're probably
going to get a Sharper Image here's the
thing though the flaring that's coming
off the iPhone lenses you're starting to
see that already with lights this has
always been a problem with the iPhone
cameras for quite some time I want to
see how bad it is or if it's improved
here on the 4G Pro Max but with this 12s
Ultra pretty much no flaring whatsoever
they control it very well there's
probably things to Leica and some other
technology and what they're sharing with
sell me but this is a big difference
versus the iPhone when it comes to lens
flare anyway let's go on the Alley let's
take some low light shots and see how
well these perform stress test baby all
about the stress test watch your step
looking at these two images right here
you're going to see that the xiaomi's
got a much better bokeh much much better
and it's not using a portrait mode this
is straight out of camera this is the
deal with this a larger camera that
you're going to notice in this and
that's where this depth of field this
natural depth of field is going to come
into play now of course I could do this
a little bit more you know enhancements
with portrait mode on the iPhone but
we're not going to get there just yet
we're still playing with the camera as
it performs natively
but I gotta say between these two
it's close but the depth of field the
more naturalness to the image goes to
the shadow
this is cool with the lights well that's
cool now this is
looking at those two images here Apple's
Reds are much more of a punchier red
where the xiaomi's more got more
somewhat of a pink Hue again you can
change the colors from Leica authentic
to like a vibrant on the xiaomi that's
kind of your two color choices on that
but I would say that in terms of
exposure I might give it to the xiaomi
for being a little bit brighter the
iPhone seems to be a little bit darker
in that situation trying to balance
everything out but
hmm I'm gonna take that back I think
iPhone's exposing better it might not be
as bright but you're seeing more detail
in the shadows in the darker areas
versus the xiaomi which you're going to
see a much more brighter highlights and
darker Shadows More film masks more that
kind of vibe versus where the iPhone's
gonna probably try to expose everything
properly anyway let's shoot some more
lights and some more uh for this let's
get down to it
what's up
iPhone xiaomi which one you like better
uh now let's uh hope both are better
which one opal which one iPhone which
one out of these two photos what do you
like better
this is xiaomi
okay he says xiaomi's better
I gotta say in this image I gotta agree
with it the xiaomi takes it thanks man
thank you so much thank you we're going
deep into the darkness you better pump
it that ISO there's you know
okay so people are not normally going to
shoot in this kind of a dark situation
but we're pushing these cameras a little
bit so I'm going to actually pump this
up here and of course I've uh Apple's
got the ability to
with deep Fusion
and this photonic engine to really
expose
for brighter areas
and that's pretty good that's pretty
decent with the exposure on that detail
as you can see the LG uh
aircon unit
that's with the xiaomi and that's
with the iPhone
now here's the thing
Donald you probably can't even see me at
this point in time so I'm going to just
light myself up here
what you're seeing out of the camera is
probably closer to the iPhone the xiaomi
almost looks like it's Sunset versus
night time this looks more like night
time so I would say the more realistic
image is the iPhone
but if you want that kind of brightness
at nighttime then the xiaomi is going to
be the winner in that but in terms of
detail this one inch sensor you are
going to let in more light so I will
give it to the xiaomi for the detail in
a lower light situation okay now we're
going to try portrait mode with the
iPhone now if you first get your iPhone
14 pro pro Max or even for the 14. you
might be noticing that your portrait
remote look a little aggressive with the
bokeh very strong reason being out of
the box it's now set to 1.8 where Apple
used to set it to 2 point or F4 which
has a more natural closing the aperture
down a little bit but makes it look a
little more natural for a phone versus a
standard camera anyway
setting this here would have 4.5 let's
bring this down to 2.8 okay take a photo
like that and now you have one two and
three times
now we're going to go to the xiaomi with
this portrait mode you just have one
vocal range is about a two compared to
Apples let's set it to
2.8 to be the same
okay all right looking at these two
images here which are about
close as we can to get to each other I
would say the color for the xiaomi wins
on this regards a little more greenish
Hue but in terms of the bokeh
if we zoom in
it might be a tad sharper around the
xiaomi but at the natural fall off on
the iPhone looks a little bit more
realistic so for me most natural bokeh
would go to the iPhone but in terms of
color and in terms of detail I'll give
it to the shaman let's go see these guys
playing some chess let's go shoot some
images over there usually they're pretty
friendly about it
foreign
night mode kind of similar to what Apple
has with their kind of longer exposure
but it's more aggressive than Apples
would I would say so when you turn it
off you get a much more balanced
exposure but I'm going to give it to the
iPhone much more better detail on Lower
light in this regard where the lights in
the background it's more in focus
the players are more in Focus so I got I
mean based on what I'm seeing on the
screen right now iPhone wins
if this is what I wanted to do with a
mirrorless camera this is exactly how it
exposed this unfortunately the iPhone
didn't fare so well it Overexposed it
and as real result looks a little bit
hazy not as sharp whereas this one just
pops now this is what I'm saying with
the xiaomi sometimes gets so right so so
right and the iPhone misses it but
there's other times the iPhone Nails it
too so man this is tough it's tough to
say but in terms of image quality both
of these are doing very very well
this one inch sensor is a difference you
are going to notice it but when it comes
to the other cameras the other lenses
it's gonna be hard to say but you know
we haven't tried Xena
macro
that's it Apple's got the best macro on
a phone hands down
this is freaking impressive really
impressive that's all I need to do one
durian shots you know we got it we
already know what's gonna happen
Apple wins let's try this shot this is
interesting highs and lows this is
interesting
dude the iPhone balances that out really
well
look at that
much better
really well controlled
so as you could tell both of these
cameras win in some areas and they lose
in others this was not as easy of a
battle as I thought it was going to be
my personal opinion I thought the xiaomi
with the winning sensor would really put
the iPhone to shame but it did not as a
matter of fact the iPhone 1 in many of
these categories when it comes to video
especially but I have to hand it to the
xiaomi for that very much more organic
look in the better exposure in Lower
Lights but when it comes to the overall
performance of a camera phone
I have to give it to the iPhone 14 pro
Max I think they've done a tremendous
job with this brand new sensor and all
the other cameras in that regard but
this xiaomi is just a beautiful camera
in that Leica color anyway those are my
thoughts let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below if you like
this video hit that like button
subscribe and if you like this video
check more of our reviews right here